[Musica]
vi è capitato di vedere per la prima
volta una persona senza neanche
conoscerla e senza neanche che possa
parlare e aver pensato Mamma mia che
antipatica che è questa persona qua ecco
a me è capitato e Immagino che anche a
voi sia capitato ma la cosa che mi
faceva star male è che dicevo Ma sono
una brutta persona non la conosco
neanche non so neanche chi è questa
eppure il mio cervello ha già emesso un
giudizio E allora lì mi è venuta la
curiosità di studiare come funziona il
cervello e ho iniziato a studiare le
neuroscienze e mi sono accorto che il
cervello purtroppo ragiona troppo
velocemente e alcune volte magari fa
degli errori Allora se vi va Vorrei
portarvi con me a scoprire queste trame
del cervello e che caratteristiche hanno
Eccolo qui questo è il nostro cervello è
un giocattolino straordinario pensate
che in questo momento è l'organo del
corpo umano che è più studiato Ma è
quello di cui Il grande pubblico conosce
meno perché noi pensiamo di memorizzare
di decidere sempre razionalmente invece
gran parte delle nostre decisioni
avvengono in maniera irrazionale allora
se volete vi faccio conoscere un po'
Come funziona il nostro
cervello 35.000 sono le decisioni che in
un giorno prende il nostro cervello sono
tantissime una valanga incredibili da
pensare e in realtà il nostro cervello
quando Pensa queste 35.000 decisioni lo
fa in maniera veloce vi faccio un
esempio e oggi quando siete entrati qui
eh avete deciso di sedervi in un
determinato posto facendo i ragionamenti
diversi Ad esempio Qualcuno ha detto mi
metto davanti perché l'anno scorso era
un po' più indietro quindi ho gli anni
precedenti e non vedevo non vedevo dove
ci si poteva sedere alcuni invece hanno
fatto un ragionamento opposto mi metto
dietro perché quelli che sono davanti
sono i secchioni quindi ecco a scuola
funzionava così No ognuno di voi ha
fatto un ragionamento molto semplice che
attingeva i propri ricordi alle proprie
esperienze e che senza nessuno sforzo
cognitivo si è posizionato Qui invece
altre scelte ci richiedono molti sforzi
se io vi chiedessi ieri Quali sono le
decisioni che vi ricordate di queste
35.000 probabilmente ne ricorder reste
10 o fino a 100 e sono quelle in cui
avete realmente scelto qualche cosa di
inedito rispetto alle vostre scelte
tradizionali 15 sono i secondi che ci
mette il nostro cervello per fare un
riassunto cioè ogni 15 secondi il nostro
cervello fa quello che si chiama un Time
Lapse cognitivo torna indietro fa un
recap fa un riassunto e dice questa cosa
è importante la tengo questa cosa non è
importante la butto nell'inconscio
Pensate solo 15 secondi 10 secondi
invece sono il tempo che ci impieghiamo
ad esempio a scegliere un prodotto nuovo
allo scaffale andiamo al supermercato
prendiamo il prodotto dallo scaffale lo
guardiamo decidiamo e in 10 secondi
decidiamo se buttarlo nel carrello o
rimetterlo nello scaffale pensate 10
secondi meno di uno spot
che dura 15 secondi to invece sono i
secondi che servono per catturare
l'attenzione del nostro cervello se in 8
secondi il cervello non viene catturato
vaga da altre parti Se ne va perché dice
Non è importante non so se ve ne siete
accorti ma le ultime canzoni di successo
Hanno un intro che dura esattamente 8
secondi voglio farvelo
sentire
8 secondi pochissimi tutti l' Avete
riconosciuta e pazza musica di Mengoni e
Lod questa canzone in 8 secondi deve
catturarti se non ti cattura cambi
stazione radiofonica oppure nella tua
playlist quella canzone esce se vedete
pochissimi secondi per raggiungere
l'obiettivo di memorizzazione set invece
sono i secondi che ci mettiamo per
prendere una decisione Quindi prima
quando ho detto di quella persona che
era antipatica ci ho messo solo 7
secondi pochissimi quindi allora diamo
una cosa per scontato Io non sono una
brutta persona voi non siete delle
brutte persone ma il nostro cervello che
va troppo veloce e porta magari a delle
decisioni che non sono corrette quattro
invece sono i secondi che ci impieghiamo
quando abbiamo ulteriori scelte
ulteriori scelte più variabili potremmo
dire ad esempio nell'esempio dello del
prodotto a scaffale 4 secondi per
scegliere quale prodotto prendere valuto
il prezzo altri 4 secondi decido quale
prendere altri 4 secondi pochissimo
tempo quindi avete capito che il nostro
cervello va velocissimo ma andando
velocissimo non è detto che ci porti
sempre alla soluzione migliore Infatti
potremmo dire che due sono le domande
che dovremo porci perché il nostro
cervello va così rapidamente e la
seconda è Quali sono le modalità
attraverso il quale il cervello ha dei
pensieri automatici era il
1984 quando una psicologa americana
Susan fisk Al termine delle sue ricerche
arrivò alla conclusione che le persone
hanno una capacità limitata di fare di
utilizzare delle informazioni di
conseguenza che cosa fa il nostro
cervello prende delle scorciatoie lei le
chiamava scorciatoie mentali che se da
una parte ci aiutano perché ci danno
l'idea immediatamente di quello che ci
sta capitando dall'altra parte sono
degli automatismi e quindi non è detto
che ci portino alla soluzione migliore
perché infatti lei diceva il nostro
cervello Cerca la soluzione più veloce
col dispendio di energia possibile
infatti nell'esempio che vi ho fatto
prima quella persona che mi è risultata
antipatica sostanzialmente aveva in sé
tutti e degli elementi che io
attribuisco di antipatia a persone
diverse e questa persona Sfortunatamente
ce li aveva tutti ma è mica colpa sua
mica è colpa sua se a me quelle cose
stanno antipatiche e quindi ho
attribuito a quella persona qualche cosa
che non le non le spettava che non era
suo in realtà Magari Peri quella persona
conoscendola mi è risultata anche
simpatica perché Allora il nostro
cervello funziona così perché il nostro
cervello si dice tecnicamente che è un
avaro cognitivo non ha voglia di far
fatica vuole fare il minimo sforzo di
conseguenza Cerca dei percorsi veloci
per arrivare a una conclusione facciamo
un giochetto assieme guardate questa
immagine se vi chiedessi Che emozione
stanno provando questi due ragazzi
sicuramente mi direste sono contenti
Sono felici guardali sono innamorati
sono uno vicino all'altro no E mentre vi
ho fatto questa domande il vostro
cervello ha fatto Questo ragionamento ma
in
contemporanea alcuni di voi hanno
pensato guardando questa immagine Ma
quanti Tati aggi hanno ma serve farne
così tanti ma guarda questa ragazza ce
li ha fino al collo non poteva essere un
po' più sobria Oppure qualcuno ha
pensato eh qui comanda lei vedi chi c'ha
la carta di credito in mano guarda lui
guarda suo linguaggio del corpo e succo
Bed di lei altri avno pensato ma no ma
guarda che stanno arredando la casa
nuova Vedi c'è una casa vuota di
conseguenza stanno comprando sul al
computer in un sito stanno comprando i
Mob per la casa nuova Ecco Queste cose
le avete aggiunte voi non sono in realtà
in questa immagine quindi attenzione
perché il nostro cervello attribuisce
delle cose alle situazioni che vede alle
decisioni che deve realizzare attingendo
i propri ricordi alle proprie esperienze
e non sempre sono corrette perché non
sappiamo niente di queste due persone vi
faccio vedere un'altra
immagine Ecco alcuni di voi subito
quando ho visto i numeri han detto No
con la matematica io per carità non
abbiamo a che fare L'ho odiata già
scuola non ne parliamo anche qui eh
qualcuno di voi invece un po' più
prestante che cosa ha fatto 17 * 49
uguale Intanto voglio dirvi che l'uguale
non c'è l'avete aggiunto voi l' aggiunto
il vostro cervello perché il nostro
cervello è anche simpatico aggiunge
delle cose pertinenti evidentemente e
qualcuno ha fatto 17 * 49 è difficile 49
* 10 490 + 7 No è troppo difficile e 18
per Insomma avete tentato di trovare la
soluzione se vedete in questo caso il
vostro cervello ha fatto fatica a
arrivare a una decisione dale a un
risultato perché perché non avevo
un'esperienza pregressa di conseguenza
In questo momento il cervello ha fatto
più fatica Quindi quello che dovremmo
domandarci è perché il nostro cervello
fa fatica perché il nostro cervello è
configurato per prendere un numero
limitato di decisioni al giorno e
Raggiunto il limite non possiamo più
prendere indipendentemente da quanto
siano importanti quindi vi do un
consiglio la sera quando arrivate a casa
e dovete dire una cosa importante a
vostro marito vostra moglie vostro
moroso vostro morosa ai figli dovete
fargli prima una domanda prima di dirgli
Questa cosa importante dovete chiedergli
scusa a livello di cervello come siamo
messi come limite ci siamo perché tanto
se glielo dite non lo ricordano se sono
a
34.900 non se lo ricorderanno mai e
quindi è bene prevenire piuttosto che
curare e anche perché le ultime ricerche
di neuroscienze stabiliscono che la rete
decisionale nel nostro cervello
Addirittura non dà priorità voi potete
dire Ti devo dire una una cosa
importante ma se il cervello è già pieno
non dà priorità perché funziona la
regola chi prima arriva meglio alloggia
di conseguenza come sceglie il nostro
cervello il nostro cervello sceglie
attraverso dei loop Cioè ha delle degli
elementi meccanizzati che noi abbiamo
imparato voi da casa vostra andate a
lavoro o andate all'università andate in
posti che conoscete automaticamente il
vostro cervello spende poca energia
perché ha imparato automaticamente che
cosa fare Come avvengono questi
automatismi attraverso tre modalità la
prima la maggior parte delle decisioni
si prendono inconsciamente vi ricordate
le persone che vi sono antipatiche che
non hanno fatto niente poverette l'avete
fatto inconsciamente seconda modalità le
scelte avvengono per categorizzazione
Dobbiamo immaginare il nostro cervello
come un grande supermercato dove ci sono
gli scaffali se è una cosa che viviamo
durante la giornata esattamente come un
prodotto da mettere nello scaffale non
c'è problema Se invece c'è qualche
cos'altro ci darà più da riflettere
Quindi sarà più difficile da posizionare
terza modalità le decisioni sono
regolate da pensieri rapidi e semplici
vi ho chiesto l'emozione di questi due
ragazzi in realtà voi avete pensato
tante altre cose oltre a quello che
avevo chiesto di conseguenza sapendo
questo vorrei darvi tre consigli tre
consigli che vi possono aiutare a
lavorare meglio con le trame del vostro
cervello Primo consiglio è bene
conoscere bene il cervello perché Perché
si vive meglio perché allora la sera
quando arrivate a casa invece di
arrabbiarvi con la persona che è a casa
che vi sta aspettando e invece di delle
cose importanti sapete che se non vi sta
ascoltando non è che non vi vuole bene
non vi ama no sostanzialmente il
cervello è al limite non ce la fa più e
quindi non è colpa sua secondo consiglio
siate curiosi dovete essere curiosi
perché il cervello siccome Cerca dei
percorsi tradizionali non può crescere
Invece noi dobbiamo trovare dei percorsi
inediti perché questi saranno più
difficili ma ci daranno molta più
soddisfazione e ultimo consiglio vorrei
dirvi che il cervello avete capito che è
pigro vuole fare poca fatica Allora il
consiglio che vi do è di studiare
studiare studiare perché solo conoscendo
il nostro cervello potrà superare quei
loop che magari sono semplici ma abbiamo
visto che ci portano a degli errori
perché io credo che se si vuole vivere
una vita felice dobbiamo solo utilizzare
un cervello che sia creativo e che non
utilizzi i loop
[Applauso]
Grazie